well nevada is stepping up to provide
more resources for residents who are
facing mental health issues millions of
dollars are now being invested thanks to
the american rescue plan
since the pandemic more and more people
have been struggling over 42 thousand
calls were reported last year in nevada
the doctor stephanie woodrow tells us is
only going to grow a big concern she
says as mental health continues
impacting nevadans and americans across
the country the number one indication is
is it having an impact on your ability
to live
day to day is it impacting your
relationships your ability to get up and
go to work thank you all for being here
on tuesday governor steve siselek
spearheading the nevada health care
provider summit to strengthen the
state's health care while announcing a
20 million dollar investment from the
american rescue plan act to improve
crisis centers the health care system in
nevada we need some work you know we
don't rank where we want to rank in
terms of health care and as i said the
covert has shown us some of our
weaknesses we're desperately short of
health care providers particularly in
the nursing category governor siselek
says the state will work with the
schools to attract more people into the
medical field the governor also getting
a boost from the biden administration to
combat mental health with the launch of
a new 988 hotline we want 988
to be as good
as 9-1-1 is when it's time for an
emergency in addition to that in nevada
we're looking to really fund what's
called the crisis care hub so that if
you need additional support and resource
beyond the phone call
we'll have the ability to really see
what is available in your area
well the 988 hotline will be active on
july 16th and according to secretary
vessera it will consolidate the suicide
prevention hotline and other resources
into one a crucial number he says that
will be available right here in nevada
and across the country